jacob and bibi thanks for doing this
what do you think the film was about
there are these people that
can communicate with wolves
we didn't know the wolf walkers are real
they can heal people
and jump really high would you recommend
the film to your friends
yes it's really good this is my number
one
favorite movie we watched it like three
times
oh cool three times whoa how many films
do you think you've seen so far
a hundred two hundred whoa
i'm not sure if jacob actually watched
100 movies
i watch a lot of movies you know what an
oscar is an oscar is an award for
shows and movies would you give would
you give wolf walkers an oscar if you
had one
i like the oscars the animation award
have you learned the lesson from that
movie what do you think it would be
stay where you're told to stay stay
inside
do as you're told really is that the
lesson you think you got from the movie
oh oh dear after watching the film would
you like to visit ireland
after the pandemic yes of course
did you think there was a difference
between the way that the town was drawn
and the way the forest was drawn
i think the town was more straight and
the horse is more wavy that's exactly it
the animation is so good
do you think jacob does it make you want
to draw the characters yourself
yeah i just drew you guys
that's good so if you were in the forest
and you saw some wolves
what would be your reaction there after
seeing wolf walkers i think this
story is more fiction so i'd still be
afraid
i think just leave them alone i think
the best thing is to leave them alone
let them live in the forest
[Music]
bye
you